css3 introduces image set a new value
for the background image property that
lets us specify different background
image files depending solely on the
display density this won't let us change
based on layout size but we can do that
using a media query this works great to
switch between different versions of the
same image purely based on pixel density
if that's all you need that is your
layout size and pixels won't change and
you don't mind using background images
if those are good for you this is the
way to go foreground images are a bit
trickier because you'll either end up
with invalid HTML and no source
attribute with problematic accessibility
or you'll end up downloading an image
you don't need in the high device pixel
ratio cases this is one place you
probably don't want to roll your own
solution but use a library to polyfill
until we get the right solution there's
a great article written by Chris coiler
that has a collection of solution
libraries that he and Christopher
Schmidt put together my personal
favorite of these is the picture fill
polyfill because I think it's most
likely to be relatively close to the
eventual standard solution in its markup
but there are many other techniques with
differing complexity for example the
clown car technique designed by Estelle
while this technique makes use of SVG
encapsulation to make each image a
single reference but to an SVG file that
inside it has its own media query that
selectively sets a background image on
the SVG object background image again in
order to prevent the browser from
downloading all of the image references
early this technique is quite workable
but it's also a bit complex and markup
particularly if you want it to work in
Internet Explorer